Speaker 1: lying. Republican Congressman George
Santos has told so many lies genuinely, and I'm
not saying this just as kind of a phrase. I mean,
genuinely, it's hard to keep up with all of the
lies that he's told. Well, one of the lies he told
was that his mom died in 911. And we already knew
this was a lie. Or at least he was lying about
one of the claims he had made about this topic
because he said his mom died 911. He said both of
his parents survived 911. And he said that his mom
in 2021 died five years in the past, which would
not be 2001. So something had to be off there.
And now we understand it has been confirmed
based on immigration records that indeed he
was lying. So let me remind you about this
first, and then we'll take a look at the
new reporting. Here's him saying both of his
parents were down there on 911 and survived.
Speaker 2: I can't believe that that's
the reality that we're living in,
that I have to hear somebody actually say that
the 911 memorial cancel the same memorial where
many New Yorkers in Long Islanders and even
New Jersey and Connecticut residents perished.
First responders, law enforcement, everybody, you
know, people working the towers, the media people,
everybody that just perished. And I get emotional.
My parents were both down there on the day of the
attacks, and fortunately, none of them passed.
But to see that the families of those who lost
their loved ones will will be recused from that.
Speaker 1: Okay. So you see that there. And then
also, which is a very contradictory. He said that
his mother died on 911. As you'll see a tweet up
on the screen here. 911 claimed my mother's life,
claimed my mother's life. But then in a different
tweet, he said, December 23rd and this is in
2021. This year marks five years. I lost my best
friend and mentor. Mom, you will live forever in
my heart. So again, I say all those things can't
be true simultaneously. Both of his parents can't
survive 911. His mom died at 911 and his mom
died five years before 2021. Really doesn't
make sense. And now we know for sure that
he was lying here. From The New York Times,
Representative George Santos of New York has said
consistently that his mother, Fatoumata Volta,
was working at her office in the South tower of
the World Trade Center during the September 11th,
2001 attacks, Even as he altered his official
biography to remove other false claims, Mr.
Santos's account of ties to the tragedy remained.
But official immigration documents reviewed by the
New York Times on Wednesday directly contradict
that claim, too. And an application for a visa to
enter the United States filed in 23. Mr. Holder
said that she had left the country for Brazil in
June 1999 and had not returned since an earlier
paperwork filed in June 2001, three months before
the attacks. Mr. Holder said that she had been
unable to return to the United States since 1999
because her green card had been stolen in Brazil.
So now we have confirmation. He was definitely,
definitely lying. Absolutely. And each one of
these revelations is stunning to me because I
just can't comprehend it. And I was explaining
on my show, kind of asking myself the question
for the audience, why do I keep talking about
this? We get it. He's a liar. Why has every
single revelation have to be discussed? And to me,
it comes down to fascination and accountability.
I am fascinated with a human person, a human
being who lives in the same world I live in. Being
able to be this dishonest, this deceitful, this
vile and his dishonesty goes beyond just normal
dishonesty that we see in politics. He picks the
worst things to be his eyes about pulling from
drawing from the trauma and the devastation of
people saying that he lost employees in the Pulse
nightclub shooting, saying that he had Holocaust
survivors in his family, saying that he had his
mom either survive or die in 911 and all of those
things weren't true. That is so horrible. And so
it's fascinating because I can understand it and
it's wild. And then also, if we are going to hold
him accountable or I should say, if he's going to
be held accountable, which it doesn't look like he
will be, it's going to be because it stays in the
public conversation. And it's unfortunate because
it looks like the only chance for accountability
is going to come either with his legal troubles
or with his if he tries to run for reelection
in two years, the Republican Party standing
behind him. And that tells you a lot about
the modern Republican Party. But all in all,
just really wild stuff. Make sure you subscribe
to The David Pakman Show the YouTube channel.
Then also, if you like, what you're seeing here,
as I'm guest hosting for David today, follow my
YouTube channel. Subscribe to it. Luke Beasley
on YouTube. Quick break. We'll be right back.